[Music]
you're about to have a baby any moment
now like in a few weeks
Lauren is due Italy yeah yes good memory
and she she's like do like it could go
down she's not here right now because
she's at home and and she should be she
should be but it could go down sooner
like yes Jasmine came early and we are
anticipating not like having
contractions right now is she no well
not right now I'd be in trouble if she
was having contraction to you yeah I get
my ass kicked that's not good but but
she has that feeling you know mamas have
that intuition they're like I don't know
we're gonna she thinks is coming early
she does do you have an emergency plan
we do we do yes we have this massive
tour that I have to go on I have to go
to Shanghai I have to go to London I'm
not gonna let you well we we have Plan
B's all set I'm ready to pivot at any
time okay were you going to Shanghai
well again we the baby was due on the
25th so right now we're rolling the dice
but I'm but I'm ready to come back
believe me the pilots all ready to turn
that plane around if things start to
happen oh you got a name there's two
there's possibly to you but we've been
possibly it's here tears on the board et
spoke with Dwayne the rock Johnson at
the premiere of his new action film
rampage his 16 year old daughter Simone
with ex Danny Garcia also attended the
event so it could be early anything
could happen and maybe tonight tonight
are you guys have an emergency plan in
case it happens you know they have an
emergency plan and we support them we'd
say go go go what's your plan for like
helping to take care of the new baby if
I'm getting honest baby they're not
really my thing
but I figured since they're gonna be so
busy taking care of the babies I'll just
take care of the dog that way I can help
you
[Applause]